[Applaudissements]
démago but et pour mac ou encore need
and go mc ou à coca cola forme pouce aux
élèves collège madame nous avons décidé
d'aller à la rencontre des grands
personnages doublés de sites mari
[Musique]
comment j'ai découvert le bénin la chose
la plus mondial c'était d'être tout le
temps dans les coupes et l'observation
jeu comme vous avez vu vous avez écouté
vous avez envie de toucher pour la
relation otan boult aux bois à la peau
parce qu'elle tombe boissons moon
tamboise éléments vivants
elia béria mais qu'il ya c'est avant
tout une société basée sur l'initiation
du tambour et dont eux sont venus des
pays lointains avec le rythme et ils
nous ont transmis toute cette
philosophie de biéville d'harmonie
descend là se passait sur le retard de
peugeot des faits ou l'activer à benoît
stock chanteur madame amara bamba k
broussailles camo 12 ans les bois de la
première fois qu un tremblement mapei et
puis après on a dit bon et au cabinet
passé pour tenir sur la terre il ya un
message audio al assad travail sa part
oui vraiment boisé calbou qui calebasse
gbagbo a beaucoup coucou biggie bâti ps
dément point amicaux mais guy laliberté
plumes au ralenti baraja bégayant qu'aux
pièces pour mon expérience unis d'où
makelele bali ben oui c'est un chanteur
avoue jean claude mignon entêtement donc
à partie et puis et puis à montréal et
on l'a précédée
ensemble en laye en garantissant à
l'oeil
ils l'aiment parano mono'i passable y
avait un garçon il ya un petit coup de
com' sa junte et mac os google pour mac
ou mac os weinstein bamako ako work
diaphane coulis mac os ou coran était un
franc mac os voire à des gosses est miss
boye ou kaka des point & click ou mené
intelligemment comme c'est le cas ici à
cause même la crise et où il avait la
prostate ou au passage que jean bouin
ouvert à coups bas coûts l'ailé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
puis nous avons rencontré paul rastocle
le frère de benoît tanbouyé vous avez
toujours sa main toulousaine pour les
mémoires il chante elle avoue dépité à
l'âge de 12 ou la deuxième usine le
tambour ils font la chantaient tous les
ponts des balades et bois appelée
d'embrouillés à l'écouté
gad elmaleh ou café et puis s'il est au
petit matin là mais à l'époque comme la
ligue nord-pas-de-calais ou du génome à
l'arraisonnement vous est trop petit
sortie enfin nous avons pris félix quasi
russe autre grande figure du bellay qui
nous a reçu dans son pit
[Musique]
le monde l'avait tu m'as miley m'enlever
mon trouvais pas mon style est alors
début mai les gemmois tous les vents de
me laisser damien mandat c'est bel et
moi je jouais tambou tabou des tabous
damier c'est l'envié ni la crise ça veut
nous avons aussi joué nous replonger
dans ses belles et puis jouer à sète
hérault soir pour au moins sept
animateurs aussi toute la nuit partie
beaucoup mûri des cadeaux c'est super
mais n'atteignant nos quartiers pour
tout l'été les plus bas dans ses invités
de monde
nicolas davouze et être aimé briller
c'était bois ou sa connaissance à cette
marche c'est la fête patronale un
symbole eh oui mais attendez ça c'est un
bois
cette milice rebelle sous une veste le
loup garou a pilé et où on lisait sur
les canidés récession et la montée
morizet très bel
nous sommes retournés voir roland
pavilla artistes et grand connaisseur du
bellay à se battre
[Applaudissements]
tous promettent à la séniorité
détracteurs musique bel air et qu'on
vend ou par télépathie cas tombe au parc
ajoute ou pas tout ceci s'est cantonné
au monde bourg le nom musiques du monde
musiques damon donc tambours et musique
mode c'est une musique ou rebellyon donc
le blé ou baylet blé baylet c'est en
musique de résistance
dubai mall avoir banni piquant des
pailles mandat leoni à dbayé oblin
malabo en libye quand et où gigabit chez
we do do - tielen mois ces départs les
autres salaires à ses 500 enfants se
faire les dents l'école très l'époque
c'était travail caritatif et se
connaître comme ça livni il promis 12 44
12a les mettre au travail à petit
plainte est liée par grasset nos bonnes
heures du matin alain d'obliger par une
possibilité pour une telle icône de la
france ne pratique à souffrir d'une ou
deux pas des halles elle sautille
travail nous aller était la doctrine la
nati bonne et prendre de la boule et
bill
un soir un mois fait est bonne à l'âge
de 11 ans passé m'a pas fait l'école
matisse et mais robert points
on choisit au maroc dans ce cadre j'aime
arriver avant par tigani soit libellé
tyrannie d'un milieu de quatre mois
s'est jouée épuisé les routes marocaines
après dita a prédit mais les dégâts qu'a
commencé la blesser des personnes
démunies cabinet des noms qui tombe au
bon moment alors prix fort au canada pas
de la méthode à saissac et d'amis sandé
tout cas de la santé très dangereux
dernier
rethel dans l'es10 d'amis le magasin
attentats la commune va pas mettre la
faute à bout d'amiens l'eau monte pas
jouer c'est la mort il ya besoin gable
du jeu de dame au chapeau à son nom
ginette ginette oui hélas à balma et la
relève est assurée la wii
déjà joués on serait mon frère aîné il
remonte elle à lyon lyon et une face à
reading loin le temps à paris
alors
on peut
des fois la ddtm à partir de 10h et dans
mon cas fabregas et -10° de mangas des
délits menant alors tout trempé allez
allez faites trop tarder elle un dernier
round
il est allé passer si mon guide et ça
c'était à la mode le triton madrid
continue tout ce qu'on aurait jamais eu
ça fait de la peine c'est qu'il me
fallait laisser la peau au bâti
moderavy rester jusqu'à était fini
mokssit là c'est mon café n'est pas
valide riner est maudit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]